hoy estoy súper emocionada porque le
podéis estar enseñando este vídeo de
newsweek esmeró con miriam en donde
repasamos todos los pasos de cómo se
hace una cesárea voy a poner el vídeo
aquí en la pantalla y ahí podemos ver el
vídeo juntos y voy a estar es de un
comentario de cómo se hace necesaria y
por qué hacemos algunos pasos bueno
vamos a empezar un parto por cesárea
generalmente conocido como cesárea es un
procedimiento quirúrgico en que se
realizan incisiones en el abdomen y
útero de una mujer para dar a luz un
bebé
algunas cesáreas se planifican sin
embargo a menudo la necesidad del
procedimiento se torna evidente después
del inicio del trabajo de parto cuando
las condiciones anormales hacen que un
parto natural no sea seguro para la
madre o su bebé
aquí quiero parar el vídeo rapidito es
un parto vaginal un parto natural es lo
mejor para la mujer como la mamá y
también para el bebé pero me lo estoy
bien agradecida que tenemos la cesárea
hay muchas condiciones médicas donde es
necesario o para la mamá o para el bebé
para hacer una cesárea también a
situaciones de emergencia en la en una
cesárea es necesaria vamos a seguir las
indicaciones comunes para el parto por
cesárea incluyen listos ya placenta
previa y sufrimiento fetal la distancia
o trabajo de parto no progresivo
prolongado puede producirse cuando la
cabeza del bebé no cabe por el canal del
parto o su cuerpo se encuentra en una
posición desfavorable como por ejemplo
cuando está perpendicular al canal del
parto o de nalgas como lo es la posición
de nalgas este vídeo está tremendo me
encanta enseño exactamente lo que está
pasando no me habían dicho muchas veces
si el bebé viene de la ncaa no puede ser
un parto vaginal y pues tenemos que
hacer una cesárea como vieron en el
vídeo la placenta previa se presenta
cuando la placenta se encuentra en una
posición baja y obstruye de manera
parcial
la abertura cervical el sufrimiento
fetal se produce cuando la salud del
bebé se encuentra en peligro inminente
por lo general debido al flujo
insuficiente de sangre a través de la
placenta o el cordón umbilical en
alguien el vídeo pueden ver que este
bebé tiene el cordón umbilical alrededor
del cuero hay muchos bebés que nacen así
y no tienen ningún problema pero en
otros casos les puede bajar el latido
del corazón el bebé y hay que hacer una
cesárea y sufrimiento fetal puede
producirse cuando la placenta se separa
de la pared del útero antes del parto o
el cordón umbilical se comprime o
estrangula
pero para el vídeo aquí para hacer una
explicación de cuándo se separa la
presenta de la matriz cuando esto
ocurrió durante el embarazo es una
emergencia y si hay que hacer una
cesárea de emergencia cuando se separa
la placenta de la matriz o el útero pues
en esta ocasión el bebé empieza a perder
sangre muy muy rápido otras afecciones
que pueden requerir un parto por cesárea
incluyen nacimientos múltiples
tumores grandes del útero herpes genital
u otras infecciones o problemas médicos
tales como la hipertensión o la diabetes
no controlada
el médico puede utilizar el ultrasonido
y un monitor cardíaco fetal que le
ayudarán a decidir si el bebé nacerá o
no por cesárea cuando sea necesario
realizar un parto por cesárea se le
preparará para una cirugía si aún no se
le ha colocado se le colocará una vía
intravenosa y se le insertará un catéter
esto es que me encanta está explicando
todos los pasos que pasan antes de una
cesárea sobre más a decir que tú eres
una persona que ahora tiene una cesárea
programada viendo este vídeo te debe de
dar un poco de paz porque ahí vas a
saber todos los pasos ser en la vejiga
para drenar la orina
en la sala de operaciones se le
anestesiar a en la mayoría de los casos
se administra una anestesia espinal para
adormecer la parte inferior del cuerpo
sin embargo algunas veces se utilizará
anestesia general el médico comenzará
realizando una incisión en el abdomen
será una incisión vertical justo debajo
del ombligo hasta la parte superior del
hueso púbico o con mayor frecuencia una
incisión horizontal en forma transversal
y justo por encima del hueso púbico a
esta insistió en en general se le
denomina incisión de bikini en este
vídeo es que está fenomenal hoy es
violencia ción que usualmente usamos es
la que es la de bikini como explicado en
el vídeo ahora primero hay que pasar
todas las capas pero es con la piel un
poquito de grasa hasta llegar a la
fascia después separar los músculos y
ahora cómo vamos a ver en vídeo no
llegamos a la matriz el útero para
sacarle el bebé una vez que se abre el
útero su médico romperá la bolsa
amniótica si aún está intacta y el bebé
nacerá el tiempo que transcurre desde la
incisión abdominal inicial hasta el
nacimiento es por lo general de cinco
minutos
luego
de naical porque vieron que tuvieron que
sacar las piletas primero extraerá
cuidadosamente la placenta y suturar a
bien el útero y abdomen generalmente
esto dura alrededor de 45 minutos por lo
general la estadía en el hospital
después de un parto por cesárea es de 3
a 5 días durante este tiempo se le
recomendará que am amante duerma cuando
el bebé duerme y se levanta de la cama a
menudo aunque la mayoría de las
pacientes pueden ocuparse de su bebé
recién nacido después del procedimiento
la recuperación completa puede tardar
entre 6 y 8 semanas la cicatriz se irá
aclarando a medida que sane
en vela que este vídeo me encantó me
gustó mucho que empezaron de todo lo que
va a pasar antes de la cirugía
explicando qué pasa durante la cirugía y
también el proceso de la recuperación de
la cirugía yo espero que les haya
gustado mucho este vídeo a mí estos
tipos de vídeo a mí me encantan porque
pienso que ayudan mucho a los pacientes
en explicando exactamente lo que
nosotros estamos haciendo como médicos
este vídeo es una colaboración entre mi
canal de youtube audio y bar en ti y el
canal de newsweek es mera comedia en mi
canal de youtube yo he creado un espacio
donde yo puedo hablar sobre todos los
temas que tienen que ver con la salud de
la mujer y quiero indicar mi canal de
youtube les voy a dejar el link de abajo
en la descripción yo me la haciendo un
obstetra ginecóloga me encantó el vídeo
creo que es porque yo pienso que las
cesáreas son una de las cirugías más
cool del mundo bueno espero que les haya
gustado el vídeo y nos vemos en el
próximo y enfrenten el amor a todo el
mundo que está alrededor los quiero
mucho nos vemos bye